- On this episode, I talk
about kimchi, oh yeah kimchi.
I talk about preparing for
a public speaking engagement
and I talk about the timing
of when this show goes up.
(upbeat hip hop music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching the
#AskGaryVee Show Episode 19.
Fun fact about the number
19, that number was worn
by one of the great all-time
New York Jets Keyshawn Johnson.
- [Voiceover] Nam asks, "What
wine goes well with kimchi?"
- Nam, first of all, before
I answer this question,
literally as I was about
to say Nam, I thought,
you know what, this is
a cool way to bring back
some of those Wine Library TV vibes.
Next time I answer a wine
question on the #AskGaryVee Show,
the wine will be here and
I'll taste it and review it.
They're gonna like that,
you're gonna like that.
Nam, because I love that
style of food in general
as a Russian immigrant,
Belarussian immigrant,
we eat a lot of pickled
food as well, and pickles
are literally some of my
favorite things in the world.
There's a couple different
ways you can go but
for me, high acid whites have done well
or oily thicker whites,
so I'm gonna give you
the recommendation of
Falanghina white wine from Italy
and Santa Barbara russon or villone
if you wanna go USA on the wines so
those are your two little suggestions.
- [Voiceover] Robert
asks, "Why do you release
"the #AskGaryVee Show in the evening?
"Are you trying to target
to East Coast commuters?"
- Robert, great question.
I appreciate you having the respect in me
to think I have that much strategy.
I do like to say, everything
I do is on purpose.
This one though, on the other hand,
happens to completely
be on the heads of Zak.
Not usually Zak actually.
(Zak laughs)
You actually have very
little to do with it.
- Yeah.
- It has a whole lot to do with DRock
who's on the other side of this,
and it has to do everything
with my schedule.
Here we are at 9:30 or 9:40
taping today's episode,
yesterday when did we tape DRock?
- [DRock] One.
- 1 pm yesterday, obviously
that came out later.
It's 9:48, I expect DRock's mission,
with only one video question
today, to bang this out
and it should be up by 2 or 3
or 1, and we'll be out soon so
completely predicated on the insanity
that is my schedule.
- [Voiceover] Dimitri asks,
"How do you prepare for
an important keynote?"
- Dimitri, the way I
prepare for a keynote is to
think about punching every audience member
directly in the mouth.
I look at the audience as
my enemy, yet my child.
There's this kind of weird mix between
loving them with all my heart
and really wanting them
to get the message.
There's a disrespect and there's a love,
and that mix is what I do.
I'm literally like a boxer
before hitting the ring
six minutes before I take stage.
Maybe that's where Jab Jab
Jab Right Hook came from
in some ways, because I'm
literally in this crazy zone.
Eight minutes before I'm talking,
I don't even know that I'm giving a talk.
I'm like just like doing
my email, I'm just like
laughing, crying about the Jets,
like you know whatever it is,
but around six minute zone,
I go into this weird place
and I get very focused and
I say to myself, "You're only
as good as your last talk."
And so even though I've
had a great seven year
public speaking career,
none of that matters
the second I take that
stage for the next time,
because you're only as
good as your last at bat.
And so, my friend, to answer
your question, Dimitri,
the way I prepare for
a speaking engagement
is the same way I would prepare for war.
- [Voiceover] Jared asks,
"Gary, you said ignorance
"helped you innovate in marketing.
"Do you think any of
your areas of expertise
"hold you back from innovating?"
- Jared, thank you so much
for making the #AskGaryVee Show
what it is. For all you hardcore Vaniacs,
and I've appreciated all
of you, and by the way,
all the new lurkers, that means the people
watching this show on YouTube
or natively in Facebook,
'cause that's the way
I've been putting it out,
and are not leaving
comments are pissing me off.
So lurkers, episode 19, get your asses
in the comment section. It is the fuel
that helps me continue to do this show.
Jared, thank you for
making this show what it is
and what I mean by that is,
so many of you have heard,
if you're hardcore about me, which is that
that Medium post like,
maybe you'd wanna put the
picture up here like, you know,
me failing all my classes is why I'm good.
My lack of reading, my lack of knowledge
of a lot of things, that
keeps me very creative
'cause I'm not folding into things
and using the same thing over and over,
there's that, it's a big advantage for me.
My lack of education, IQ knowledge
on a lot of subject
matters, really helps me.
And so for the same
reason I say that, Jared,
the answer is yes, the
things that I believe in
or I'm more knowledgeable
about hold me back
because they get entrenched in my brain,
I believe them to be the way they are.
Now, because it's in my soul to fight
and to counteract and to go in the grey,
not the black and white,
and all that stuff,
I think I maybe get away
with it a little bit more,
but truth is, I'm still human and yeah,
those things are holding me back.
- Hey Gary, my name is Mark Cersosimo.
You might remember me
from this little incident.
Please buy Gary's book,
my life depends on it.
- Buy it!
- My question for you today is this.
I have 39,000 Instagram followers,
instagram.com/mark ,
and I average about 250 likes per photo,
but I also run the Instagram account
for the company that I work for.
- Great company, Vimeo.
- We have 6,000 followers
and we also average
about 250 likes per photo,
what am I doing wrong
on my personal account?
I must be doing something right
'cause I have the follower count--
- Alright, let's get into this.
- Help.
- Mark, couple things.
I do remember you and you're a great dude,
thanks for being on the show.
You know, there's two
things that stand out.
I took a few minutes to
look 'cause I wanted to
give a good answer here and
not just a general answer.
Number one, Vimeo is a beloved brand
to that community, more so
than you are to your community
for a couple of reasons, one.
I just think a lot of people
followed Instagram slash mark
because it's Instagram slash mark.
Right, like we saw that in Twitter days.
The people that got the
like real name stuff
have exponentially more followers
because we're like,
"Who are these people."
In a world where Instagram
doesn't have verified,
there's like who is this guy.
I literally think some
people are following you
so they think you're Mark
Sanchez or some like other Mark,
so I do believe that you have an inflated
number of followers who actually don't
give a rat's ass about
you but they're just
following you because of that name.
That's not a diss, but
that's just what I believe.
Number two, looking at
the accounts, very easily,
and DRock, put up a little
sample of both right here.
I don't know if you can frame it but like,
maybe you can go through like showing
six of the photos here so.
What do you see difference?
That's what I keep Steve
around for, grammar.
(laughing)
What's the difference
you see in these things?
Here's the core thing, Vimeo is putting
a ton of human beings in
their pictures, you are not.
And I think a strategy
of making it more human,
not just landscape and pretty pictures
would really help you.
Don't forget Instagram is a platform
that there's a lot of human emotion to it.
It's still a more authentic place
than some of the other social networks.
Though landscaping and
beautiful pictures work,
human over indexes, and more importantly,
you don't have a mix.
The problem is you don't have a mix,
and I think you need a mix of the two
and so those would be the core things.
That's it right? No more questions?
Very nice, another episode in the books.
I feel the momentum going,
I feel the momentum going
but I need more distribution,
so the question of the day is
can we make a deal?
How do I get my videos on your site,
your little blog, your company's blog.
Let's make a deal.
Are you willing to make a deal with me?
And number two, because I'm
noticing a lot of the comments
are based on the question
of the day which I love,
but unlike the Wine Library TV audience,
there isn't that core audience
yet of 50 or 100 people
that are giving me feedback on the show.
There's a little group, I
wanna expand that group.
I love the people that
really know my brand
or new people like, "Hey
I just stumbled on you
"because of this, and I
really enjoyed this, that,
"and the other thing."
The feedback loop is my oxygen.
You keep asking questions, I
will continue to answer them.
(upbeat hip hop music)